[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست
احنا في سنه
بريطانيا علامه الحرب ومش اي حرب الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
اللي حصل من سنه 1939 لسنه 1954 الفيلم
وهنا الشك هيبدا عند واحد منهم لا حرام
يدخل شقه ويخرج من غير ما ياخذ اي حاجه
خالص وقتها يبدا اجراءات تفتيش عندي واللي
هيظهر لنا فيها مين هو طيورنج وايه اللي
حصل معاه سنه 1928
شاب غير محبوب في مدرسه داخليه وبيتعرض
للتنمر من كل حوليه ملوش صحاب غير كراست
فورمر
[موسيقى]
الوقت بيمر وبنبقى في سنه 1939 بريطانيا
استخدموها علشان يبعتوا رسائل مشفره
تيورنج شخصيه صعبه جدا طفولته ما كانتش
سهله فبيتعامل بطريقه غريبه مع زمايله في
الفريق وبيقرر يشتغل لوحده بعد فتره بيطلب
من درستن تمويل اله هيشتغل عليها لكن ده
نستم بيرفض وقتها طيور الجنه هيكتب لرئيس
الوزراء وينست ريتشارد واللي مش بس بيوافق
على تمويله ده كمان بيخليه المسؤول الاول
عن الفريق بعدها بينزل اعلان في الجرائد
عباره عن احجيه او بازل كلمات متقاطعه
اللي هيحلها هيشتغل وبالفعل بيلاقي جوان
كارد واللي هتغير كثير جدا
[موسيقى]
بيقرب طيور الجنه
كورتامنا بصديقه قديم ولكنها للاسف ما
بتقدرش تحدد اعدادات تشفير النجمه بسرعه
الكثيره بعد مرور الوقت بيامر دانستين
بتدمير الاله دي وساعتها بيفصلنج وفي
اللحظه دي هيحصل حاجه غريبه جدا وغير
متوقع بقيه الفريق بيهدد دانستون انهم
هيسيبوا الشغل لو ترنسابه وبكده المكان
هيخسر لان دول افضل مشفرين في الدوله
يتعاونوا مع بعض علشان يشتغل على الاله
قبل ما الوقت يعدي وبعد معاشا شديده جدا
الاله بتشتغل فعلا وبتقدر تفك الشفرات بين
الرسائل لكن هم يكتشفوا ان الفريق جاسوس
واللي هنا هنعرف انه كارت
هيحاول يقنعه ان الصوتي
[موسيقى]
انتم وبكم ناون استيورنج ماشي
بسبب الاله الاختيارها على طيورنج بعندنا
النهارده ما يسمى باجهزه الكمبيوتر للاسف
في سبع يونيو سنه 1954 انتحرت يورنج اوف
سنه 2013 منحت الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
تورينج عفوا ملكيا بعد وفاته تكريما اللي
عمله اللي كمل للنهايه علشان يساعد
البشريه في التجاره اجهزه الكمبيوتر
من افلام السيره الذاتيه اللي هتتعلم منها
كثير خلينا الشركه الجزء من المواقف اللي
وقفت عندها وخلتنا نفكر بمنظور مختلفه
بيقول
كان كان
حتى لو الساعه بايظه ممكن تبقى صح مرتين
في اليوم ودي اشاره منه ان حتى الحاجات
الغلط فيها امل
اشتغلت بعد محاولات كثيره فاشله وعلى
الرغم من كل حوالي قالوا انها بتشتغل بس
هو كان عنده امل وامله ساعدوا ينجح
التحديات كانت مختلفه وصعبه يعني في اليوم
اللي نجحت فيه الاله وعرفوا معاد القذف
اللي جاي ما قدروش يبلغه به علشان كده
الالمنهج كشفه متعرفه الشفرات بتاعتها
بس يومها حد من الفريق قالوا لنا اخويا
على السفينه دي وتمثلي
بس للاسف هو اختار ينقذ الملايين مقابل
السفينه اللي فيها وقال صمتي
احيانا مش هنقدر نعمل الصح علشان لازم
نعمل المنطقه وقتها بيقول انهم فعلا
ينقذوا الملايين قصاد السفينه وعشان
تيورنج شخص غير عادي ارتباطه باكلارك كان
غير عادي لدرجه انها قالت له
ما تنجح بعد نجاح المهمه وكل واحد في
الفريق راح من الطريق
ومشاعر سيئه جدا وقتها بتروح وبتقول له
دينا ديسمونه
[موسيقى]
طيور الجنه على رغم انه عارف مدى تاثيره
على ملايين البشر الا انه انتحر في
النهايه لانه كان وحيد
من الافلام اللي ما ينفعش يتحكي عنها بس
لكن لازم تشوفه بنفسك ولو بتسال الفيلم
ناجح ولا لا خليني اقول لك انه ظهر الاول
مره في الولايات المتحده في مهرجان تيل
الورد السينمائي في اواخر اغسطس وتم
الاشاره به خلال موسم الجوائز حصل على ثمن
تشريحات لجوائز الاوسكار بما فيهم افضل
صوره متحركه وافضل ممثل
لبناتج وافضل ممثله مساعده لك وافضل مخرج
لتايجر وافضل كتابه وسناريو وحوار للجهاد
بالاضافه على 15ريحات لجولدن بلو وتسعه
تشريحات لجائزه وعلى الرغم من كل الجوائز
دي لان الفيلم مواجهه انتقادات لكونه مغير
جدا في الاحداث اللي مر بها الشخصيه
الحقيقيه لكن في كل الاحوال ده الايام
فيها عظم من الفيلم شوف الفيلم دلوقتي
واستنى لي الحلقه الجايه في فيلم جديد في
بودكا استماره الافلام المقدم بالعربي
[موسيقى]